Okay,
let's get started.
The stuff we're doing these few days are really the focus of the first half of
the semester,
so pay attention and uh,
think about it.
Um,
okay,
so the topics today are overlap and energy match as determinants of how strong
bonds are.
So we'll start with overlap.
We saw last time that overlap is what creates the difference density,
what focuses some small amount of the electron density between the atoms and
serves to hold them together.
The overlap integral is the total amount of that product of a and B.
Remember you square a plus B and you got a squared plus B squared plus two ab
that to a B term is the overlap.
It's called overlap because it has values.
When both functions have appreciable magnitude at the same point in space,
they overlap.
And summing that overall space or integrating it gives what's called the overlap
integral.
It'll depend on the distance.
Obviously they're very far apart.
They don't give simultaneous values to the same point in space because it's far
from either one or the other or from both.
So it depends on distance.
It also depends on hybridization and that's what we're going to talk about
first.
Okay?
First,
let's just look for scale.
Here are the two s orbitals of carbon atom and you can work out with your
formulas that the,
the diameter of the spherical node is 0.7 OnX drums,
right?
That means we have a distance scale here.
Now,
the distance between two car,
uh,
carbons is roughly 1.4,
1.5,
uh,
when they formed a bond from one another between one another.
Okay?
So that means we can use that 0.7 angst from scale to see how far we have to
slide these together in order to get them to bonded distance.
If we superimpose the x's,
remember those diameters are each 0.7.
So if we slide them together until we superimpose the x's,
then there are 1.4 angst comes apart.
So that's about the distance that these two orbitals are and the proper scale
when they're in a carbon carbon bond.
Now,
how big is the overlap integral to some of the product of a Times B overall
space?
Now I want you to guess,
guess how big that integral is,
and we have a hint.
What would the overlap integral be if we moved them until they superimposed on
one another?
Exactly.
That's the maximum we could get if the distance where zero.
So if we pulled them all together,
then a and B would be measured from the same center,
so it'd be the same thing as a squared.
Okay,
so what would the integral of a squared B overall space one.
That's normalization.
Okay,
so the maximum value can get when they're right on top of one another.
Negatives multiplied negatives to give positive positive areas multiply positive
areas to give positive everything is optimum is going to be one.
Now I want somebody to give me an idea,
a guess of how big it's going to be here,
or at least some considerations that would go into that.
The maximum value you can get is one.
How big do you think it would be here?
What's something that would hurt it
that is making it less than one Russell?
Yes.
Yeah.
On the f beyond out,
beyond the red areas,
there's very little overlap altogether.
So you lose whatever overlap you'd get from there and doing the normalization.
Now in the middle,
right in the middle,
you have blue on top of blue.
That's good.
But notice there's also a node that's going to interfere with some of the wave
functions overlapping and there's going to be a little bit of blue on top of
red.
Everybody got that?
So I just want uh,
people to guess.
Okay.
I know what I'll do.
We'll,
we'll do a poll.
This is a democracy after all.
We're about to get it to November.
So I'm going to start with 0.1 as what you think it would be right?
The maximum if you put them right on top of one another is one.
So I'm going to start with 0.1 and move up and see hands.
Okay.
How many people think it's 0.1 0.2
0.3 0.4 0.5
0.67891.
Obviously not one.
Now I think [inaudible] has been my uh,
sense of this is it peaked between 0.3 and 0.4.
But there were some votes for 0.2 and I would have voted for 0.2 cause it looks
like you've lost an awful lot here.
But in fact,
I personally am surprised that it's pretty big.
It's 0.41 it's almost half as big as it would be if they were right on top of
one another despite despite the fact that you're losing great parts of it that
they don't overlap at all.
And there's negative overlap where reds on top of blue,
because still the fact is it's 0.41 so pretty big.
Now that's going to depend on distance obviously.
Right?
So here's how it depends on distance.
There's that point at 1.4 on strums.
It's 0.41 and I've put on here for reference the distance of a carbon carbon
single bond,
the distance of a carbon carbon double bond and a carbon carbon triple bond and
zero notice would be way down out in the hallway someplace,
right?
We're only looking at the region that's carbon carbon bonds or maybe just about
to the far wall.
Okay,
here's,
here's half an obstacle.
We got to go two more halves.
Right.
Okay.
So here's how it,
how do you think,
what should the line look like?
Should it be a sign wave?
Should it be increasing as we go to the left?
Should it be decreasing as we go to the left?
What do you think
some guests
should probably decrease?
Cause cause we know it's going to approach one,
right?
And there it is.
Yes,
it decreases it.
Pardon me?
It increases as you go to the left and ultimately it'll go up to one when you
get out to the hallway.
Okay,
so that's s with us.
Now let's look at some other orbitals that might overlap and see how big their
overlap Benadryls would be.
Okay.
Suppose you have s on one overlapping with p on the other.
Now that p is called for this purpose,
Pi Pi is the Greek version of p.
In fact,
in Greek you pronounce it p not pie.
Right?
So that's the Greek letter p.
Am I right about that?
Okay.
What is it?
Which way is it?
Uh Huh.
Okay,
good.
So anyhow,
Pi now,
uh,
so that,
that symbol is used to talk about molecular orbitals or parts of molecular
orbitals where P is used to talk about atomic orbitals,
they correspond to one another.
Now what is it that characterize as a p atomic orbital has a nodal plane.
And in the same way a Pi orbital has a nodal plane that contains the nuclei that
are in question,
right?
So you'll see if those two came together,
there'd be a nodal plane in the orbital on the right that contains the two
nuclei.
Okay?
So that's called a Pi orbital.
Now,
but notice the contributions to the overlap below that plane,
you're going to have blue overlapping with blue.
So that's going to be a positive contribution.
But above you're going to have blue overlapping with red.
That's going to be a negative contribution and it's symmetrical.
So what will the total B,
what will the total overlap integral be?
The sum of all the overlaps?
One,
it'll be zero because for every contribution on the bottom,
what's positive,
there'll be one on the top.
That's the same value in is negative.
So it's going to be zero.
So the one on the left is called sigma.
Now sigma is the Greek equivalent of s,
right?
So it means for a molecular orbital what s meant for an atomic orbital,
there are no nodes that contain the the nucleus.
Okay?
So if you have a sigma overlapping with a pie,
there's going to be this symmetry that causes a cancellation.
So you can never get any overlap by overlapping a sigma orbital with a Pi
orbital.
Does that make sense to everyone?
That does make sense.
Doesn't make sense.
If you have one that doesn't have a horizontal node that's the same top and
bottom,
and you one that has the one that does have a node that's plus on the top,
minus on the bottom,
then you're going to get this cancellation everywhere and zero.
And that's called orthogonal.
Okay?
So you won't get any net interaction.
They're okay.
But if you turn the PR,
but also that it is also sigma notice,
it has a plane,
a nodal plane that contains that nucleus,
but it doesn't contain the other nucleus you're interested in.
So the the call sigma and Pi,
we need a plane that contains both nuclei that'll create this symmetry that
cancels things out.
Okay,
so this one will give overlap?
No.
What would you expect for the trend of this one as you go from great distance to
small distance?
How about if they're very,
very far apart?
How much,
how big will the overlap integral be?
Like 10 meters apart.
Zero.
Okay.
Now as you bring it together,
will it start pot,
will the or as they start coming together where you get positive or negative
overlap.
Positive.
Right.
The blue will overlap with the blue and you keep coming.
It'll get bigger and bigger and then what will happen?
Then the red is going to start coming in and uh,
well the,
the blue is going to start the blue on the right from the puppy orbital to start
going to overlap that,
that the red part on the left and then as it slides on over till they,
till they get exactly on top of one another when they get exactly on top of one
another,
what will it be?
Zero.
Because there'll be canceling right to left.
Okay,
so here's,
here's a plot of that for s p sigma overlap,
right?
It's almost the same as s with us.
In fact,
it's a little bigger at great distance,
a little smaller at small distance except at very small distance.
What will happen
when you approaches zero,
it will go to zero,
whereas the other one went to one,
right?
That's with us went to one.
So,
but in the region we're interested in of the carbon carbon bond distances,
it's about the same.
Okay.
Now how about peace sigma with p sigma?
Well,
we won't go through elaborate guessing game.
If they're very far apart it'll be zero.
How about if they were on top of one another?
It's obviously going to grow as blue on top of blue and then as they get really
close,
the blew up from there,
right?
We'll be on top of the red and the red on top of the blue.
Right.
And what will,
what will it approach Zach,
what do you say?
Approaches zero.
What will it be when they're right on top of one another?
So read on blue here.
Blue on red here.
Will they overlap be zero?
Pardon me?
It will be minus one because it would be like the orbital on top of itself.
That would be one except you've changed the sign of one of them.
Right?
So every contribution will be negative.
So that one starts there and it's heading toward minus one.
So it's going down.
Okay,
so that's p sigma with p sigma.
Can you think of any other way we should talk about,
we've talked about this with us.
We saw that s with p pie was orthogonal.
S with s with a s with a p sigma.
We've got their p sigma with p sigma.
Any others?
We need to think about.
How about p Sigma with PPI?
Can anybody guess that one
p sigma is the same sign,
top and bottom.
P Pie is opposite sides.
Top and bottom.
That's going to be zero.
There'll be orthogonal.
So we've done it now or is there anything else to think about?
We could do p Pie with p Pi.
Okay,
so there's a p Pie with p Pie.
Okay.
Now what?
At great distance,
there'll be nothing will bring them together.
They'll begin to overlap.
What will let approach as we go to zero,
zero.
If they're on top of one another,
the product to be zero,
it'll be one,
right?
It'll be the orbital with itself normalized.
So that'll be one.
Right?
But now how do you think is going to be bigger p signal with peace sigma or PPI
with p Pie.
And he guesses.
I'll give you the answer,
right?
P Pie with P [inaudible] is approaching one at big distance.
It's smaller than sigma,
right?
But it's small distance start.
It must get much bigger.
And in this region it's crossing,
so it's bigger.
Okay.
So there are the,
the kinds of overlaps of simple two P orbitals.
Uh,
now there's a curiosity here over on most of this range,
more than half of the range.
Two s overlaps with two p sigma better than either two s with two s or two p
sigma with two p sigma.
That just seems curious to me.
You'd think that one of them would have a shape that gives better overlap.
Right?
So two of those together would do the best job,
but it's not that way.
It's that an s with a p is the best over most of this range.
I just think that's curious and it has an important implication,
which you'll see right now.
What if we use hybrid orbitals that are partly yes and partly p.
Now since this one is partly s,
it's s plus a certain amount of p,
this one's asked with a certain amount of p.
The overlap will be s here with s here as here with p here as here with p here
and p here with p here,
right?
There'll be four contributions to the s with us p with p s with p with us.
Right?
So if we took the p Cube for example,
and we can make you remember for such orbitals,
uh,
then you get that it's better than,
than any of the pure hybrids.
Right?
And the reason is that it has that it has s with s and p with p and also s with
p that comes in as a bonus.
Right?
Twice.
Okay.
Now.
How about if we use instead of s p cubed?
How about if we use SP squared?
Remember what happens is we,
as we approach sp,
the orbitals extend more.
So what do you expect?
More overlap.
So there's SP squared with sp squared a little better.
How about sp with sp
better still?
Could we get any better?
How about s squared?
P With s squared P or s p one half with sp one half,
right.
It's a little better at short distance at about and a little lots of good at
long distance.
So it optimizes around sp hybridization that gives the best overlap.
Why do you want,
why do we think now you want good overlap?
Why would it be good to have good overlap?
Because that's what's building up the difference density as we saw last time.
Right?
That's putting the glue in the,
in the orbital.
Okay.
So there's an interesting observation here that hybrids overlap about twice as
well as pure orbitals.
Right?
All the hybrids are roughly twice as good as the,
as the pure ones.
Okay.
And they're not very,
very different from one another.
But sp is about the best over a bunch of this range.
The trouble with sp is you can only make two of them because each involves 50%
of acid.
You only have one s to go in it.
You have one s and three P's.
So if you want to make just one orbital fine use sp cause it,
you'll get good over.
Well only one,
uh,
bond from the carbon fine use,
use sp and get the best overlap or maybe even s squared p right?
Depending on the distance.
Right?
But if you want to make more bonds,
if you want more than two bonds,
then you're going to have to cut back on the s in each bond.
Cause you only have 100% to use.
You can't use more than 50% in more than two bonds you're making.
Okay.
And what you see here is that s p three isn't much worse than sp squared.
So why not make for right?
Cause you can,
okay.
Anyhow,
that's the hybridisation of carbon.
So,
and the reason they do this,
as I already said,
is because they allowed nearly full measure of s with p overlap plus s with s
and p with p when you have mixtures.
So that all depends on the fact that sp sigma is so good and it's overlap
now.
So sp gives the best overlap but only allows two orbitals with 50% in each SB
three gives four in nearly as much overlap.
Okay.
Now we're going to look at the influence of overlap on molecular orbital energy.
But we're gonna use Arab and meets goldilocks just for familiarity.
So we're working here in just one dimension to get the idea of it.
And we'll also then think in more general terms,
and we've already done this,
so it's partly review.
So we'll assume that there's perfect energy match.
That is the two Adams were talking about.
Of course Adams would be cool.
Alembic potential's not harmonic oscillator Hooke's law potentials.
Right?
But the idea of a double minimum is the same.
So we'll,
uh,
we'll suppose that the atoms are equivalent.
So the bottom of the,
well as the same on both sides.
And guess and energy and low and behold,
we were right.
We got the solution,
and you've seen that one.
Okay.
But you can also get that one one with one node,
right?
And from the on the far left,
you can see that they have the same curvature over amplitudes.
So they have essentially the same energy.
If the green energy is right,
the red energy's the same deal,
right?
They're degenerate orbitals because they're far apart.
Okay?
No significant energy difference.
Now suppose we increase the overlap.
What will happen if we shorten the distance?
You did this on a problem set with Aaron,
right?
So you bring them closer together and you have the one with no nodes and the one
with one node and now there's a little right halfway between.
There's more electron density in one than there is in the other,
right?
One has that.
The anti-bonding one has zero and the bonding one has some build up of an
electron density in between,
but the energy hasn't changed visibly on this scale that we're using.
Looks just the same.
Okay?
Now we increase it more and now there's a big difference in the middle,
right?
And now the energies are beginning to change.
One,
the,
the unfavorable orbital is going up in the favorable bonding.
Orbitals is going down in energy.
And if we get it still closer together,
uh,
we can see that there's now a big difference,
between them.
Okay,
so that increasing overlap creates the splitting that we talk about.
We've,
this is just review as you know,
but it's worth,
it's so important.
It's a,
that's good to mention it again.
Now that overlap holds the atoms together.
And this again is a picture we saw before that,
except we're going to do it with writing in the equations.
Remember,
a good guests of the form of the molecular orbital is one over the square root
of two times a plus B or one over the square root of two times a minus B.
And that will give to new orbitals one better in one worse.
And in fact,
if you try,
if you think about normalization,
it should be a little less than one over the square root of two in the one
that's going to have plus two Ab and a 20th square it and a little less than one
over the square root of two when it's going to have a minus sign for the two ab
term.
Okay?
Now because of that little bit,
a little bit greater and a little bit less,
the energies aren't quite as we saw before,
equally split up and down.
The one that goes down doesn't go down quite as much because this is less than.
And the one that goes up goes up a little more because it's greater than that.
The mathematical,
uh,
requirement for that isn't immediately obvious to you,
but it's true.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's there the new orbitals you get when you bring the atoms together.
Okay?
And if you had more overlap,
there'd be a bigger difference.
So that's why overlap is important.
The more overlap,
the more splitting.
We just saw that with in one dimension with Arab and meets goldilocks.
Now,
how many electrons do we have to put in these orbitals that's gonna make a big
difference.
So suppose we have just one electron for these two orbitals.
When we bring the two wells together would bring the two atoms together.
That electron will go down and energy to the new molecular orbital.
So that's going to be good.
And if we tried to pull them apart,
the electronic would have to go back up in energy and that would require energy
and that would be opposed the breaking.
So that's the bond strength,
right?
You have to put an electron up that much.
Now I suppose there were two electrons.
Now a second one goes down the same way so it's even stronger.
It won't in truth be quite twice as strong.
Do you see why?
Yeah,
because the electrons will repel one another.
We're not,
we haven't taken that into account when we think about the energies here,
but it'll be certainly stronger.
It's considerably stronger.
Okay.
Now suppose we had three electrons.
What's going to happen?
One of them is going to have to go up instead of down.
And in fact it will go up further than either of the others went down.
Even neglecting electron repulsion.
Right?
Because of that greater than,
less than thing.
That shifted the pair up a little bit.
Okay.
So that's going to be even weaker than having one electron to hold them together
when you have three.
How about if you have four
Wilson?
Yeah,
it'll,
you're,
you're now definitely losing because the two that go up go up more than the two
that go down and go down.
So that's bad.
So we can summarize that here.
The effect on the bond,
if you have one electron,
it's bonding.
Two electrons are strongly bonding,
three electrons is weekly bonding,
probably,
and four electrons will definitely be anti-bonding.
So that's why helium bounces off helium until it gets 52 on strums apart.
Right.
And there,
then there's this very,
very,
very weak bond that we talked about due to the correlation to the electrons.
Right.
But as soon as you get overlap with helium,
it's repulsive when you start to split these levels.
Okay.
Now.
Oh Wow.
Let's look at the other end.
Why does it increasing overlap as you bring things closer together?
Why doesn't that make these plum puddings collapse?
The electrons are getting more and more stable as you increase the overlap by
bringing things closer together.
So why doesn't it just collapse?
Yeah.
In fact,
the electrons,
if hydrogen molecule collapsed two helium,
it would be a funny helium because it would have no neutrons.
But if it collapsed,
the electrons indeed would become 55% more stable.
The electrons in helium are lower in energy than the electrons in h two right?
So that would tend to pull them together all the way to [inaudible] zero.
Why don't they Elizabeth?
Cause the protons will repel one another.
That depends on one over R.
Right?
And that increases much more dramatically in fact,
that the amount by which the electrons become more stable as 650 kilocalories
per mole or would become more stable.
Right.
But the new nuclear repulsion increases by that much.
By the time they get to 0.3 Ostrom's let alone the last little bit.
When one over r gets enormous.
Okay.
So it's not worth it unless you have glue to hold the neutrons together.
Right?
So on the sun you can take deuterium and fuse it into heat to make a helium.
You have neutrons there to hold the protons together and then you get 200
million kilocalories per mole,
which is of course nuclear energy,
not electronic energy.
It is possible,
but uh,
not an under the chemical circumstances that we're talking about.
Okay,
so here's the morse potential.
Yeah.
Lucas,
no are only sort of subliminally,
right?
Because if you take,
at first glance there's going to be nuclear,
nuclear repulsion,
electron electron repulsion between the atoms,
nuclear electron attraction,
nuclear electron attraction.
So to first approximation,
those law cancel out.
Right?
But then you get on top of that,
you have a little change from,
from the fact that the nuclear nuclear goes as one over r and gets quite big
when they get really close and that the electrons are coming down because of
overlap.
And we'd been focusing on this overlap thing that causes the bonding.
But obviously things aren't going to collapse because of the nuclear part.
But we haven't been talking about it explicitly.
You're right.
Okay.
So anyhow,
this is the form of the bonding potential,
the Morse potential,
which was just cobbled together artificially to make it convenient to calculate
things and to have a reasonable properties for a bond.
But now we understand why it should look like that.
This first part,
the attractive part is because the electron pair becomes more stable with
increasing overlap as the atoms come together,
and then the nuclear propulsion becomes dominant when it becomes too close,
right?
So all of this is cool ohms law.
There's nothing special.
There's not correlation energy,
which is some completely new physical phenomenon,
right?
It's all Coolum big correlation energy is just remember it,
uh,
an excuse to for the,
for the area or making or a way to hide it.
Okay.
So it all comes from,
from coolamons law for potential energy and that,
but the funny thing was the kinetic energy of the electrons according to
Schrodinger,
right?
Because as you make things,
as you concentrate things,
you change the curvature as well.
So you have to take that into account.
But this curve provides the potential for studying molecular vibration.
That is,
once you know the form of this curve,
then you can use quantum mechanics for the motion to the Adams,
not of the electrons,
but of the Adams.
And figure out how atoms vibrate,
which we've already done when we were doing urban meets goldilocks.
Okay.
But here finally,
we understand the Adam Adam Force law,
right?
That's what we've been doing the whole time for four weeks or five weeks or
whatever it's been right is trying to understand where the,
what the forest law is.
Wouldn't Newton be happier?
Remember he said there,
therefore,
agents in nature,
April to make particles of bodies stick together by various strong attractions.
And it's the business of experimental philosophy to find them out.
And now we found that out.
Now can we use this understanding then to gain greater purchase on,
on a chemistry?
So we've looked at overlap,
but there's one other thing we have to look at in order to apply it.
And that's what's what we call energy match.
Uh,
I don't think anybody else talks about energy match,
but we do.
Okay.
So here's what we talked about already,
right?
And we have this splitting,
which is about proportional to overlap.
It's not numerically,
strictly proportional to overlap,
but it certainly is close to proportional to overlap.
Okay.
Now,
what would happen if the two atoms you started with?
We're not the same if one was a better place for electrons to be than the other,
like their for example.
So why,
why would you remember what happened is you mix these,
you get a plus B,
an a minus B,
but why would you put any a together with B if B is already much better than a,
if they're,
if they're equal,
you don't care where it is,
then fine.
Use a 50 50 mixture.
But if one's better than the other,
why use any of the,
of the,
uh,
of the inferior one?
Why not just use the one that's good.
So we already actually saw this in the case of the one s or atomic orbitals,
which did remain pure and unmixed when we made the molecular orbitals that funny
molecule last time the,
the flouro ethanol,
remember it looked like that one of them was just an s orbital on f.
Another one was an s orbital sr brittle on one carbon Sr.
But along the other carbon,
they didn't mix.
Right?
But the next door battle,
the,
so the compact one one s Corp orbitals did remain pure and unmixed.
Right?
But the valence level,
atomic orbitals,
we're heavily mixed.
For example,
the next one was biggest on fluorine,
but also substantial on oxygen and carbon even got into the act a little bit
right now.
Why is it that the core orbitals didn't mix
and the valence or did mix?
What's different?
The core orbitals are very small,
very compact.
These orbitals are bigger.
So what happens?
They overlap,
right?
So it's overlap that causes things to mix.
If there's no overlap,
they don't mix.
If they overlap,
they mix.
So why use any of an inferior orbital?
Well suppose the energy of a is much higher,
less favorable than that of be right.
So now we,
we make uh,
some of some a weighted sum,
a parts of a,
B,
parts of B and we square it.
So we get a square parts of ace of the aid density be square parts of the bead
density and also this overlap term to a beak.
Now can you profit from shifting electron density toward the internuclear Ab
region without paying too much of the high energy cost of a,
that is a squared is higher energy than B squared,
right?
The electron density around a is higher energy than the electron density about
B.
And if you mix a with B,
you're going to get a certain amount of that bad or less good distribution a
squared.
But at the same time you're going to get some of Ab,
which,
which puts stuff in the middle at the expense of outside.
That's good,
right?
You'd rather at a certain distance from the nuclei,
you'd rather be between the new,
the new between the two nuclei,
then out beyond one of them.
So as you increase a,
you increase,
uh,
oops,
sorry,
you increase this bad part,
which you also increase that good part.
Can it be worthwhile to make a non zero,
which one is going to help?
But notice this a small,
if you put only a small amount of a man,
then the amount of a squared probability density,
this bit here is a squared parts of that really,
really tiny if a is tiny.
But the uh,
the amount of Ab you put in is a times B,
not a squared,
right?
So it's much bigger.
So you get this good stuff without getting very much of this bad stuff right
at for example,
suppose you used a was 0.03 and B was 0.98.
So you square them to find out how much,
whoops,
what did I do?
I pressed that thing there.
Okay.
You Square them and you find out that the amount of a squared you get is only
0.01 the amount of B squared is 0.96 and the amount of two ab is 0.06.
So you're getting 60 times as much of Ab is you get an a squared.
So that's why it can be useful to put a little bit in.
And you could,
if you're pedantic,
you can look at the footnote there.
So let's look at Arab and meets goldilocks in the case where the two wells are
not matched,
where the energies are a little bit different because that's what we're talking
about.
So here's here are non degenerate atomic orbitals.
So the one on the left is a little bit lower than the one on the right,
but only a teeny bit.
Okay.
Now we're going to look at the wave functions here.
So there's the lowest energy wave function,
right?
And notice it's the sub,
it's a weighted sum with no nodes,
but there's almost no mixing at all.
Just a really,
really,
really tiny amount of a in it.
So essentially it's just the,
the,
the solution you'd get in the left.
Well,
right,
there'd be one with one node as well.
What will it look?
Can you guess?
This is the one with zero nodes.
What's,
what's the wave function with one node look like?
Any guesses?
Yeah,
Josh.
Um,
it'll just have a note in the middle of that first potential.
Be Straight on the second.
That'd be what I mean.
You sort of straight up
the second one,
right?
So the first one,
the lowest one is,
is the,
the one on the left.
The second one,
the next highest energy orbital is the one on the right with just a little bit
of the one on the left in it.
Negligible amount of mixing.
Right.
And their energies.
You might think their energies would be the same,
right?
Because they're not mixing,
but the,
the green one is in this well and the red one is in that well and that wells
higher.
Okay.
So it's gotta be higher and energy.
That splitting is due only to the original offset between the wells.
There's no shift of it,
right?
It's just you have a,
or you have B and you have what you would expect for them.
Now suppose we increased the overlap between these,
what do you think's going to happen?
You should get a little more mixing because Ab is going to count for more if you
have overlap.
Okay,
so here they are close together.
You still don't have very much mixing just a little bit and you haven't seen
any,
uh,
appreciable change in the energies.
You still have that same splitting that's due to the original offset.
Okay,
now we'll bring them still closer together and now it's getting worthwhile to
put it in the wrong.
Well,
because the ab term is so important,
right?
So the,
the,
the anti-bonding energy is rising,
the bonding energy is falling.
That's why they're anti bonding and bonding.
And if we bring them still closer together,
we get that right.
Which if you look,
kid looked at it casually,
they look like a single well,
but notice that,
that they're,
they're still quite unsymmetrical there.
Still biased.
The one without any nodes is still mostly in the left.
Well,
and the one with no,
with a node is mostly in the right.
Well,
but they're heavily mixed,
right?
So what's happening is this increasing overlap as you bring them together is
fighting the effect of the difference.
In the two wells.
So when we had the core electrons and Fluor,
oh,
ethanol,
if we had tiny orbitals that didn't overlap,
then they stayed pure.
Right?
But once we went to the valence level orbitals that are much bigger so that they
overlapped doesn't,
they started mixing like this.
Okay.
Now what if the one partner is lower in energy than a,
that's the case we're dealing with.
But what will these ultimate energies be when you have this,
this competition between overlap,
which is trying to mix them and energy mismatch,
which is trying to keep them separate from one another.
So here's uh,
here's what you get.
You get,
again,
splitting but not as much shift as you got before the lower level.
We'll look mostly like c because c is better than a,
the anti-bonding.
We'll look mostly like a,
with just a little bit of CNN.
And if they had had the same energy,
you'd get a big energy shift because of overlap.
But now you get a smaller energy shift because the mismatch is fighting that,
right?
You don't want to,
you lose as you try to mix because of the difference between a and C in this
case.
Now,
uh,
so that one looks mostly like see both in shape and in energy.
That one looks mostly like a both in shape and energy,
but it's a little worse than a,
and the first one is a little better than see
now how,
how much smaller is that bonding shift when we were mismatched,
they didn't shift as much with the same overlap.
How much less exactly.
Where does it end up?
Well,
that's not so crucially important to you,
but there's a neat trick you can do to see that.
Suppose we have that much energy mismatch.
Okay.
And the red.is halfway between a and or between B C or between a and c since a
and B are the same energy now,
uh,
so when they were perfectly matched a and be perfectly matched an energy,
that's how much splitting you got from that amount of overlap.
So these are the two factors that go into it.
How much splitting you get when they have the same energy and how different the
original energies are.
How can you put those together to find out how much shift you actually get?
Well,
what we do is slide that over and then bend down the blue one so it's
perpendicular to that.
Okay.
And make a rectangle around it and draw the diagonal.
And that diagonal will be the new energy difference between the new levels.
Okay.
Then you say,
why do I make this construction?
It's because there's a quadratic formula that comes in.
So this is,
so the diagonal is the square root of the two of the squares of the two sides.
Some of the squares of the two sides.
Okay.
So we can rotate that,
put a tack in there and rotate it.
And that's going to be the new energy difference.
Okay.
And it's bigger than the original energy difference because the diag and all has
to be Dick bigger than one of the sides.
Uh,
but because of the normalization,
because one of them is a little less than one of them is a little smaller and
one's a little greater.
That was the less than greater than square root of two,
one over the square root of two thing.
It's going to shift up a little bit.
Both levels will shift up a little bit like that.
Right.
I'll do it again.
So you see it both will shift up.
So they're the new levels.
That's how you do it.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
so for a given overlap,
the bonding shift,
how much the electrons changed when the atoms came together is reduced.
If the energies aren't well matched,
if you have the same overlap,
you don't get as strong a bond from that point of view.
The energy's didn't shift down as much or up as much,
but still a plus c will be lower in energy than the original one was a plus B.
Okay.
And we had that construction,
which shows us an interesting thing,
which is the splitting is not very sensitive to the one of these contributions
that smaller,
there are two contributions.
The overlap part.
That's the black Arrow art department.
That's the Blue Arrow and the uh,
uh,
and the energy difference between the energy mismatch,
which is the black arrow.
But if one of those is very small,
like here,
the uh,
the mismatch is that mismatch,
which is black is very big and the overlap,
the blue one is very small,
but you can see that the length of the diagonal is not going to be very
sensitive to what the overlap is.
You could increase that blue overlap,
the width of the,
of the rectangle,
which wouldn't change the Diet.
The diagonal,
very much.
So it's sensitive to the one that's bigger.
Okay.
That don't worry too much about that part.
I just think it's fun.
Uh,
okay,
so we can generalize from this mixing two overlapping orbitals gives one
composite orbital that's lower in energy than either of the parents and one
that's higher in energy than either of the parents.
Okay.
The lower energy combination looks,
that is its shape is most like the lower energy parent and it's same is true for
energy right in the higher one looks like the higher parent
for a given overlap,
increasing energy mismatch decreases the amount of mixing and decreases the
magnitude of the energy shifts.
Now what does this have to do with bonding?
Okay.
The a the a minus.
The electrons are clearly lower in energy,
but that's not really what we're interested in.
We're interested in the change of energy that comes when you break the bond or
make the bond.
So which bond is stronger?
Ab or AC?
How many think a B is stronger?
You have in this scheme,
how many think AC is stronger?
It's clearly got lower energy,
electrons ac,
but this is a classic example of compared to what.
Okay,
how are we going to break the,
the,
the bond.
Suppose what we're going to do is break it to put two electrons in.
See because that's the lower energy at them or in the other case to put two
electrons in B.
Okay,
so both electrons go the same way.
Can you see anything bad about that?
Why might it be better to put one electron each way?
Heaven
not spin.
You can put two electrons in an orbital with opposite spin.
So spins not a problem.
If you only have to,
if you had three it would be a problem.
But with two it's the spin is not a problem,
but there's an obvious problem with having both the electrons go to one data,
they'll repel each other if you can put them on opposite when so much better.
Right.
But it wouldn't be possible to do this and that that that it might be plausible
in the case of ASC where C is lower in energy than a,
although the repulsion might make it better to go one on c and one on a.
Okay.
But anyhow,
suppose you break it this way,
which one is,
it would be easier to break which requires less energy.
Red Or blue?
Red requires less energy.
Okay,
so ab is stronger if you're forming a plus B minus if both the electrons are
going in the same way.
Right?
So mismatch aids,
heterologous heterologous uneven braking is to put them both on the same side
rather than one on each side.
That's called homolysis is you'll see in a second.
So if you put them both on one side,
then it easier to break.
If they're mismatched,
the bond is stronger if they're well matched.
Okay.
That's because that,
but now suppose you do homolysis and put one on each.
Now which one's easier?
Now the blue is less energy than the red.
Okay,
so now the AC is going to be stronger.
So mismatch hinders whole malice,
right?
So you can't really say which bond is stronger unless you say,
compared to what?
How are you breaking it apart?
Okay.
Is All this true?
So I've been weaving this fairy tale for you for the last couple of weeks,
but is it true what we can check that with experiment.
For example,
compare h h with Hf,
h h has perfect matching between the two Adams in HF.
There's a much bigger nuclear charge on f electrons in the valence orbital or
lower in energy on f than they RNA.
Okay?
So if we look at the sigma or but all the valence sigma orbital,
it's symmetrical in the case of h two and quite unsymmetrical in the case of HF,
it's big on f and small on h just as we were speaking of.
That's the sigma big on f right?
But there's also an anti-bonding orbital sigma star,
which has a node.
Uh,
so the,
so that one is the,
the contrary.
It's big on h small on f.
This is just what we were talking about a few minutes ago.
Uh,
and that,
and the electrons of course are only in the sigma,
not in the Sigma Star.
There are only two electrons.
That one's empty.
And that the star means that it's anti bonding,
right?
So it has the node between the nuclei,
planar in the symmetrical case and bent in the case of HF,
but it's still the node.
Now,
how about the experiment heterologous where you break in order to get h plus h
minus in one case or h plus f minus,
and the other case,
in the case of hh,
it costs 400 kilocalories to break the bond.
In the case of HF,
it costs only 373.
Incidentally,
this is a lot of energy to break this bond because you're putting both the
electrons the same place it can happen in solution,
but it's not so easy in the gas phase,
which is what we're talking about.
Okay?
So indeed we were right.
That mismatch weakens the bond for heterologous.
Hf Bond is weaker.
That's why you call it hydrofluoric acid,
right?
Because it can easily break off an age.
You don't call h to Hydrogenics acid or something like that,
right?
But if you break it into two Adams,
h two h atoms,
or an h adamant and f Adam,
then it costs a only 104 for hh,
but 136 for HF.
So the HF bond is stronger if you're breaking to Adams.
So that's the first verification,
experimental verification of what I've been talking to you about.
And we're going to go on next time to talk about x h three which,
which will have lots of experimental data that will show that this stuff is
sensible.